moi je pense que la décomplexification
totale de la haine raciale portée de
plateaux de télé en plateau télé par
exemple pendant la campagne
présidentielle par ex Zemmour ou la
conflictualisation permanente des
discours de LFI ne sont sûrement pas
sans effet aussi sur ces radicales mon
sentiment et que le modèle démocratique
aujourd'hui est sérieusement sauvagement
quelquefois sévèrement contesté par une
frange ultra radicalisée de la
population qui s'exprime avec davantage
de virulence et apparaît désormais
convaincu de l'éventuelle recours à la
violence pour se faire entendre je crois
que aujourd'hui l'ultra droite et
galvanisé et elle s'attache même
d'ailleurs à lutter contre des
événements qu'elle estime décadents
notamment en lien avec la communauté
LGBT on a vu leur mobilisation sur pour
empêcher un concert de Bilal Hassani
même si sur l'ultra droite on retrouve
les les cibles classiques le musulman le
Juif l'immigré le franc-maçon et
l'ennemi de gauche et c'est toujours
présent aussi dans les manifestations
quand il y a une confrontation
je crois qu'en plus il y a un phénomène
qui aggrave tout cela c'est l'influence
suprémaciste anglo-saxonne qui pousse la
trait vers les armes à feu et qui
donnent plus de dangerosité encore au
phénomène on a vu Frédéric clignool en
2020 sans parler d'un fusil automatique
d'un Glock et tué trois gendarmes qui
aujourd'hui je le dis est au panthéon de
l'ultra-droite les activistes d'ultra
gauche ont des méthodes différentes qui
cherchent à se greffer à des
manifestations qui sont en général
incapables d'organiser et ils cherchent
à les pénétrer dans le but de
l'éradicaliser de les faire dégénérer
dans une perspective insurrectionnelle
le premier les premiers actes du
mouvement des gilets jaunes ont été le
terrain de l'ultra-droite d'ailleurs dès
le 24 novembre j'avais évoqué les
séditieux d'ultra-droites ça mettait
sérieusement reproché j'avais d'ailleurs
critiqué Marine Le Pen qui avait
interrogé sur le pourquoi on ne
rassemblait pas et on autorisait pas les
rassemblements sur l'âme de Triomphe et
les Champs-Élysées
ce qui est intéressant dans le sujet je
veux pas te propose politique sur ça
dans le sujet qui vous intéresse c'est
de voir comment les premiers actes
étaient ceux de l'ultra-droite et puis
ultra gauche qui au début une participe
pas à ça on pourrait évoquer les raisons
pour lesquelles participent se dire il y
a une opportunité avec la stratégie du
Coucou de l'ultra gauche qui consiste à
aller dans un mouvement global et à
vouloir le faire dégénérer et donc dès
l'acte 4 l'ultra gauche s'est battu dans
les rues face à ceux qui étaient
mobilisés de l'ultra-droite à gagner et
ensuite à occuper l'espace pendant la
suite des manifestations faut avoir en
tête qu'il était aussi difficile à
l'époque de distinguer les casseurs des
gilets jaunes radicalisés et des
éléments d'extrême droite et d'extrême
gauche qui à un moment donné tout ce
petit monde se retrouver allègrement
pour marcher ensemble dans la rue